this week president-elect joe biden
unveiled a 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
plan aimed at combating the pandemic
and spurring economic recovery a
cornerstone of the plan is to provide
fourteen hundred dollars in direct
payments
biden wants to in his new plan
um send another fourteen hundred dollars
in direct payments to people who
received them under the last plan
so between the six hundred dollar
stimulus checks that went out in the
last bill
biden wants to add another fourteen
hundred dollars on top of that
so people will get a total of two
thousand dollars
in direct payments from the federal
government the covid19 vaccine
is another key priority in this plan
with 20 billion dollars set aside to
speed up distribution
and make the shot free for everyone in
the country biden
also wants to spend 50 billion on
testing
and 10 billion dollars on manufacturing
pandemic supplies in the united states
he also has made a point of
acknowledging the virus has hit
certain communities of color
disproportionately to the rest of the
country
and wants to increase funding for
underserved areas
there will be 130 billion dollars set
aside to help the majority
of k-8 schools reopen within the first
100 days of biden's administration
190 billion will be allocated to loans
and grants for struggling small
businesses
as part of the plan biden also wants to
send another 305
billion dollars to state and local
governments and that's a big deal
because in the last bill
that provision was left out completely
because of objections from republicans
even though democrats have been saying
for months and months that it's so
essential to you know make sure
government workers stay employed to let
states have enough money and resources
to be able to distribute vaccines
but republicans viewed that money as
kind of what they called a bailout
for you know states that hadn't managed
their finances very well and it was a
huge point of contention
in the last piece of legislation biden
is also calling for a 15
an hour federal minimum wage as well as
billions to be spent on helping renters
pay their landlords
he also wants to temporarily increase
the size of two tax credits to help
provide more cash to low-income workers
and families the 1.9 trillion dollar
rescue plan
is the first part of a two-part
initiative the second of which biden
wants to introduce in february
that plan will include investments in
infrastructure manufacturing
and clean energy to bolster the economy
in the long term
biden is calling on congress to pass the
first round of relief soon after he
takes office on january 20th
biden has said you know again and again
that he wants this bill to be bipartisan
that he wants
democrats and republicans to get on
board so
they can pass it kind of as a show of
unity in you know in the federal
government
and the price tag of the bill alone kind
of makes you think maybe he won't be
able to do it you know
at almost two trillion dollars this this
new bill
is quadruple what a lot of republicans
were willing to spend last year and so
you know it's it's reasonable to expect
a lot of resistance in the gop to
spending that much money
biden has an option which is to push the
bill through
a special press in congress called
budget reconciliation
and if he did that he would only need a
simple majority which is
50 votes that means he would need every
single democrat
on board and if he lost a single one
he'd have to go to the other side of the
aisle and get a republican vote to make
up for it
so that's tricky too and both of those
things mean that
you know what whatever legislation
congress ends up drafting or passing
could very well look pretty different
from what biden introduced tonight
you